[موسيقى]
تيك توك التطبيق الاشهر بين الجيل زد
اكتسح الاجهزه الرقميه عالميا خاصه في
اوروبا وامريكا لكنه واشنطن ما تزلقلقه
حيل امنها بسببها هذه المنصه التي تعتبرها
امريكا كعنون صينيه للتجسس عليهم وبالفعل
حظرت 16 ولايه تطبيقات تيك توك في مقره
العمل ووفقا موقع وورد فان الجميع امرت
ايضا بالانتصار لمنعه الصين حاولت احتواء
المشكله وابدت استعدادا لاخضاع المزيد من
اعمالها لتدقيق الخارجيه كرساله تربت على
بيض اطمئن لا يمكننا ان نصل لبياناتكم
الشخصيه
لكن الصفقه ما تزال على حالها
لان الخطه تتضمن تعيين مراقبين ومفتشين من
الخارج وثلاثه مدققين مختصين بالامن
السيبراني يضمنون حذف بيانات المستخدمين
الامريكيين وظائف ستتكفل بدفع رواتبها
شركه بايتنز الملكه لكن صفقه مع اوريكيل
شبه منتكسه لان عروض العمل يتنافس عليها
المرشحون المحتملون منذ ديسمبر الماضي
وحسب مستشارين امريكيين فان الصفقه علقت
وليس معلوما اذا كانت ستستانف نهايه الشهر
الجاري
[موسيقى]